même si les lycées restent fermés les
élèves eux continuent d'étudier par
internet pour étoffer l'offre
pédagogique en ligne
l'académie de versailles a mis en place
plusieurs master class avec des
intervenants de grande école
la première thématique était dédié le 13
mai dernier à l'oral du bac de français
deux jeunes qui planche comme une
émission de télévision si vous voulez
avec des enseignants qui les assistent
qui les accompagnent et puis 500 élèves
derrière derrière leur écran qui
s'identifient à ces jeunes qui sont en
train de travailler sur l'euro l'eur
aura la deuxième master class avec yann
algan d' un économiste au sujet du coc
vides et des incidences économiques du
covin a réuni plus de 1000 personnes
on était complet le choc du courant
navires us ne s'arrête pas là l'offre
retenue hype et applique les autres
thématiques abordées l'épreuve du grand
oral qui sera au programme du
baccalauréat l'année prochaine au total
trois masters classes ont été proposés
aux élèves de l'académie
un dispositif qui devrait perdurer je
crois vraiment que ces formats gagnerait
à partir de la rentrée à être développé
en faire pourquoi pas une fois par mois
avec vraiment des grands témoins et ce
travail préparatoire des enseignants des
élèves et de ses grands témoins ensemble
prochain rendez vous virtuel organisé
par l'académie de versailles le 26 mai
pour la remise des prix nombreux
harcèlements